bitte was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem 9 mio wie heute ich
hoffe natürlich jedes gut ist auch hier
wieder nach so dass mit dem mikrofon ihr
war auch schlecht heute zu sehen dass
irgendwie bin ich darin nicht so gut
das ist scheiße
so wird das jetzt schon passenden
haustier könnt mich ein bisschen
verstehen aber das ist ja so leute ich
freue mich sehr hier heute zu sitzen und
dieses video drehen zu können weil er
eigentlich dachte ich das wird nicht
klappen oder ja vor drei oder vier tagen
kam ein video ich habe die letzte
mediamarkt mystery box ersteigert über
ebay das war wirklich so dachte ich die
letzte weil wenn man ein media-markt
wundertüte eingegeben hat kam irgendwie
nur dass ich habe allerdings die
nachricht von einem zuschauer bekommen
die ich euch sehr gerne erst mal
vorlesen würde weil das ist sehr sehr
wichtig und zwar derjenige mir
geschrieben 9 alex habe jetzt schon
länger deinen youtube-kanal verfolgt
indem du einige mystery boxen geöffnet
hat ich habe mir letzte woche freitag
einen mystery box von media markt bei
ebay bestellt die kam aus dem mediamarkt
rauenstein und ich habe mir direkt 2
bestellt beide jeweils für 9 90 euro 99
und da soll ein warenwert von 276 euro
99 drin sein
die box ist noch viel trauriger als die
letzte die duh geöffnet hat da sind
vielleicht 30 euro warenwert enthalten
ich habe im media markt nun eine
beschwerde geschrieben und warte noch
auf die antwort aber ich finde es auch
cool wenn du so eine box auf seinem
kanal öffnen würdest um den leuten zu
zeigen dass ihm hier mag damit betrübt
ich weiß dass in jeder box das gleich
ist weil ein kumpel dass halt
aufgestellt hat also das war so die
nachricht erhalten hat und dann habe ich
mir die box wo angeschaut und es gibt
tatsächlich auf ebay
also man findet das gar nicht wenn du
halt nur mediamarkt wundertüte eingibst
aber es gibt diesen mediamarkt
traunstein und der verkauf über ebay
diese mystery boxen für 99 euro 99 ich
muss sagen ich habe keine ahnung wo dies
traunstein liegt auf jeden fall habe ich
vorher noch nie gehört wenn ihr aus
traunstein kommt könnte es ja mal in die
kommentare schreiben
das hier ist das produkt mystery
mediamarkt box in einem 40 liter outdoor
beck inklusive 50 euro mediamarkt
gutschein auf dieses bild davon ist
alles andere als vertrauenswürdig aber
es wird tatsächlich über diese defizite
mediamarkt traunstein ebay seite
verkaufen er verrückt und ich habe das
direkt mal bestellt weil ich wollte der
sache auf den grund gehen
und ja ich hole mal kurz das paket so
sieht das ganze aus ich mache mal kurz
hier einmal meine adresse direkt hier
kann man sehen kommt von mediamarkt
traunstein die soll jetzt ein warenwert
von knapp 300 euro haben und ist
tatsächlich nicht schwer also die weg
maximalen kilo deswegen viel kann da
nicht drin sein
wieder schon gesagt hat aber es würde
mich sehr wundern wenn da jetzt
tatsächlichen ursachen im wert von 30
euro bringen werden also dass er
wirklich ein krasses eigentor von
mediamarkt traunstein
aber bevor wir die allerdings öffnen
kleinen moment wir befinden uns mitten
im alex wie adventskalender und weil es
heute und media markt geht darf ich mir
verlosen wir ein paar airports von media
eigentlich könnte ich auch mal wieder
was krasses rauszuhauen ich habe da noch
so viel liegen am 24 kommt auf jeden
fall drei von zwölf einfachen kommentar
schreiben irgendeine kontaktmöglichkeit
von euch sei es instagram oder e mail zu
schreiben und dann wird der gewinner
über meinen instagram ich habe macht das
eine story ein zufallsgenerator dann
irgendwie 134 tagen ausgewählt und alex
wie abonnieren das ist natürlich ganz
wichtig und wir machen jetzt mal hier
die box auf ne so sagt so kann man jetzt
tatsächlich nur dieses dieser autor beck
drin wie auf dem foto oder angezeigt das
war ja letztes mal auf jeden fall anders
wenn ihr das video noch nicht gesehen
habt schickt auf jeden fall ab da habe
ich eine für 35 euro nur bestellt halt
über ebay ersteigert für 100 euro und
das war wirklich so eine mediamarkt
wundertüte da war so ja eigentlich war
da nur rods drin aber ihr könnt euch ja
gerne anschauen also ich ziehe jetzt
einfach mal eins nach dem anderen raus
und wir schauen ob wir wirklich auf
diese knapp 300 euro warenwert kommen
ich bin so gespannt
also als erstes haben wir hier einen
kaffeebecher vakuum markus auto den
kannst du da so ja entweder du kannst
irgendwo dranhängen oder einfach ins
auto stellen muss ich sagen ich hab ja
erst sechs davon stehen deswegen sind
auch ne was kostet es an welcher
vielleicht zehn euro weiter geht's als
nächstes haben wir hier
deluxe travel kit ach so okay das ist
soll friseur to go suite von der
verpackung her schon ein bisschen älter
aus muss ich sagen aber müssen wir
gleich mal schauen was das kostet hier
ist ein rasierer drin
hier sind fähren drin pings hätten und
kam eigentlich könnte ich das ja mal
eben aufmachen und also weiß ich nicht
da ist heute alles drin was man so als
friseur brauch mit damit kannst du einen
geilen undercut verpassen seinen kunden
ich bin leider kein friseur aber gut
habe ich schon wieder neuen rasierer
wir hatten einfach in den mystery
paketen jetzt schon drei rasierer also
das ist der dritte und er macht mir an
sich auf einen guten eindruck muss ich
auch mal gleich nachschauen was das
ganze kostet ich würde einfach mal so
schätzen bestimmt 50 euro also ich
glaube mit diesen beiden sachen hier
diese 30 euro von denen der typ da
gesprochen hat schon deutlich
übertroffen oder was heißt deutlich aber
schon ein bisschen die haben wir eine
handy hülle die ist nichts mehr wert die
wird auch für ein älteres handy sein so
wie die aussieht
das hatte ich beim letzten paket auch
schon drin mund und nasenschutz masken
kein plan warum media markt das im
sortiment hat aber gut hat ja an sich
absolut nichts mit elektronik zu tun
aber kann man zurzeit immer gut
gebrauchen acht stück weiter geht's aber
was ist das denn meine power bringt oder
power bringt mit usb von hama ich denke
mal auch das dem laden so sicherlich 15
bis 20 euro kosten sollte aber wenn wir
gleich mal nachschauen kann man auch was
mit anfangen auf jeden fall also wir
sind auf jeden fall schon einige sachen
drin
das hier ist ein leuchter okay das finde
ich sogar ganz lustig das ist so ein
tannenbäumchen kann es ja auf den tisch
stellen hier sagte festsaugen und dann
kann das die farbe wechseln du als
weihnachtsdeko ganz nett aber ich kann
damit nichts anfangen aber kost ja
sicherlich auch fünf euro weiter geht es
mit der nächste sache den nächsten zwei
sachen was ist das denn ach so das ist
einmal das gehört anscheinend auch zum
warenwert dazu das ist hier einmal die
verpackung von diesem auto rucksack ich
denke mal so ein ding kostet sicherlich
auf 20 euro oder der hat an sich eine
ganz gute qualität wenn man so ein
abenteuer typ ist und oft so in der
natur unterwegs ist kann man damit
bestimmt was anfangen und hier haben wir
dann noch eine
blu ray disc vom chiemsee wunderschön da
sind wir früher immer dran
vorbeigefahren als wir im skiurlaub
gefahren sind teile ich mich mal sehr
gut daran erinnern haben da immer eine
pause gemacht der chiemsee ist echt ein
sehr schöner see vielleicht war da ja
auch schon macht deswegen wenn ich mal
ganz ganz viel langeweile habe werde ich
mir diese dvd vielleicht mal reinziehen
weiter geht's hier mit ach so ja hier
war dann glaube ich der autor rucksack
drin die sind ein bisschen kreativ da im
mediamarkt traunstein das muss man den
lassen weil das ganze in so einen
outdoor rucksack zu packen finde ich
schon cool also finde ich auf jeden fall
cool als einfach so eine standard media
markt dann haben wir hier noch das
gehört wahrscheinlich auch dazu und hier
haben wir dann noch eine wer hätte es
gedacht habe schlüssel oder handy case
verpackung anti sleep at für auto und
ach so hier ist das abgebildet das
kannst du so ans armaturenbrett vom auto
packen und da dann halt deine sachen
aufbewahren oder dein handy reinlegen
wie auch immer hier ist ein samsung
galaxy s3 mini drin oder s3 das spricht
auch nicht unbedingt für aktuelles
produkt aber gut so dann haben wir hier
noch zu unternehmen nicht zu guter letzt
schon wieder kopfhörer diesmal von
thompson zu wireless headset headphones
ähm ja die haben sicherlich auch ein
wert zwischen 30 und 50 euro gesehen an
sich ganz gut aus muss ich gleich mal
nachschauen aber trotzdem ist jetzt
wirklich noch nichts dabei gewesen
durchsage geil damit kann ich persönlich
jetzt mega viel anfangen ohne dass wir
das jetzt falsch versteht also die
sachen sind alle brauchbar aber zum
beispiel bei den saturn boxen hat mir
dann schauen was drin was echt geil wo
ich mich selber darüber gefreut hat
natürlich habe ich das meiste auch
wahllos aber trotzdem ihren wir da noch
eine taschenlampe
die ist jetzt nicht aufgeladen das ist
keine batterien aber kann man auch
gebrauchen und das müsste es dann jetzt
auch schon das war schon also wir hatten
jetzt 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 und mit der
autor beck zehn produkte drin also ob
das hier 270 euro wert ist glaube ich
nicht schauen wir jetzt mal nach was ich
auch noch sagen wollte
viele haben gesagt ja alex das macht
eigentlich gar keinen sinn weil media
markt und saturn das ist ja an sich eine
firma deswegen kannst du das ja gar
nicht miteinander vergleichen
trotzdem würde ich dazu sagen es wird ja
schon jeder media markt in jeder saturn
von irgendwelchen verschiedenen leuten
geführt die dann auch entscheiden können
was in dieser kisten reinkommt deswegen
finde ich schon dass man
unterscheiden könnte und wenn diese
saturn boxen viel besser waren als die
von media markt kann ich das ja auch
sagt der stadt marl hier mit diesen
dingen den finde ich hier tatsächlich so
für circa würde ich mal sagen gar zwölf
bis 15 euro sagen wir einfach mal kommen
ja kostet 15 euro dieses travel shaver
kit kostet aktuell 99 euro allerdings
das neueste davon
dieses hier ist bestimmt schon ein
bisschen älter deswegen will ich das
jetzt einfach mal so mit 60 euro
berechnen okay gut diese hier gibt es im
internet für zehn euro bei expert.de mit
399 versand also die sind wirklich an
sich auch nicht mehr viel wert diese
power bank berechnen wir mit zehn euro
und der rest hat eigentlich keinen wert
also vielleicht alles zusammen noch zehn
euro geschätzt wenn überhaupt ist aber
netterweise auch mal wieder eine
rechnung mit drin und hier steht drauf
das waren es insgesamt 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 produkte die jeweils mit 16 euro
berechnet wurden und dann noch einmal
war es stand da nicht eigentlich auch da
ist doch ein gutschein mit 3p schutz
zwei jahre einmal preisten 20er handy
haben wir noch ein zwei jahre wird 20
euro berechnet auf irgendwas habe ich
hier garantie einfach mal stumpf eine
garantie geben bevor ich sonst gar nicht
brauche für 20 euro also ein gutschein
habe ich da jetzt auch nicht drin
gefunden ein bisschen überfragt nicht
schon und ich muss auch sagen vielleicht
also ich kann es absolut nachvollziehen
dass der typ sich auch sehr verarscht
gefühlt hat weil ja das ist halt nicht
einmal 100 euro wert und ich habe dafür
selber jahrhundert euro bezahlen weil
hier ist es jetzt nicht so schlimm weil
ich mache das für video aber wenn du als
normaler kunde dann wirklich 100 euro
für aus gips und dann so eine chance
kriegt ist halt schon sehr blöd dann was
das ganze aber noch verrückter macht
selbst hier in der rechnung sind elf
produkte aufgeführt die mit jeweils 16
euro berechnet wurden 16 11 sind 171
aber halt nicht 270 sowie ist ja im
angebot beschrieben wurde
deswegen kann ich euch auf diese box
absolut nicht empfehlen und ich kann
verstehen wenn sich leute deswegen
beschweren na ja gut ich habe es
probiert ich hoffe dass wir dadurch
gefallen das sehr gerne daumen nach oben
da abonniert den kanal und wir sehen uns
immer morgen wieder beides ja auch
einfach schon weihnachten
leider kann man natürlich echt nicht
viel machen dieses jahr wir sehen uns
aber vorher auf jeden fall noch mal
wieder
bis dahin bleibt gesund das war haut
rein